voilà c'est marent la la force que
peuvent avoir les images comme ça sur un
sur des jeunes quoi c'est c'est c'est
cette archive me plaît
beaucoup la violence me fait horreur
mais euh c'est un exorcisme lorsque je
la traite dans le dessin ou dans
euh ou dans la couleur c'est une archive
que j'avais envie de revoir depuis très
longtemps et que que j'avais jamais revu
en fait c'est une interview de Bilal
pour le 20h de France 2 j'ai vu quand
j'avais 14 ans c'est à l'occasion de la
sortie de son album froid Équateur qui
est le 3è tome de la série nicoopo cette
ce reportage m'avait fait un très fort
effet quand j'étais en 3e je me rappelle
très très bien je me rappelle j'avais
déjà décidé que je voulais devenir
dessinateur de BD mais sauf que les
dessinateurs de BD on n entendait jamais
parler on c'était quand même un choix
professionnel
très très incertain et moi j'adorais
moebus Dr et Bilal et cette archive donc
m'avait suivi pendant longtemps dans ma
tête et j'en avais gardé comme souvenir
que
Bilal racontait qu'il travaillait la
nuit qui se levait à 4h du matin pour
faire ses BD alors qu'en fait quand je
l'ai revu là cétait parce qu'il y des
travaux en bas chez lui et que ça ça
l'ennuyait Bilal réveillé au son des
marteau piqueur c'est une chance pour
les lecteurs àid de connaître la suite
des aventure de nicopole grâce à ces
travaux depuis un an 7h du matin je suis
levé très tôt j'ai pu terminer mon album
à temps l'album c'est froid Équateur une
histoire d'amour sur fond de
totalitarisme économique nous sommes en
2034 et le futur entre délire et réalité
que nous propose Bilal n'a rien de
rassurant et donc pendant des années je
me suis dit mais Bilal il se lève à 5h
du mat pour bosser moi je vais pas faire
de Grass mat je vais me lever aussi il y
avait un autre détail aussi qui m'avait
marqué c'était que un moment il passe
dans son couloir et il y avait un
tableau sur le mur et j'étais persuadé
que c'était un tableau de lui donc je me
disais déjà il affiche ses tableau chez
lui c'est un ryocérose vert un petit peu
avec des des des des des petits dessins
exotiques de je sais pas une sorte de
recherche picturale je métais dit tiens
c'est marrant je je connais pas Bilal
enfin je vois pas Bilal faire ce genre
de dessin donc pendant quelques temps
j'ai fait ce genre de dessin aussi en me
disant je vais faire son style je vais
le je vais le copier et cétait très
drôle de me rendre compte en voyant
cette affiche qu'en fait cé je crois que
c'est un dessin de loual plutôt que
j'adore aussi par par ailleurs mais
voilà c'est marant la force que peuvent
avoir les image comme ça sur un sur des
jeunes quoi c'est
c'est cette archive me plaît beaucoup sa
série nicoople là est quand même une
bande dessinée très très drôle même si
on pense souvent que c'est très sombre
moi je trouve c'est très très drôle moi
j'estime que le monde est beaucoup plus
noir plus dur que ce que je représente
moi je le représente avec avec un recul
un peu humoristique quand même je dire
ça peut faire sourire que moi je parle
d'humour mais j'aime beaucoup l'humour
et et j'estime que dans que dans fr
Équateur il y en a quand même pas mal il
y a une chose avec Bilal qui le qui les
yeux le rendaient différents de moohebus
et Druet alors moebus et Druet c'était
quand même des auteurs que j'idolatrai
totalement par leur capacité à aller
dans l'imaginaire le plus complet et à
s'abstraire de politique ou s'abstraire
de d'engagement social ou je sais pas
ENF voilà tout ce qu'on peut ils étaient
vraiment dans une forme de surréalisme
un petit peu Bilal il avait quelque
chose qui me fascinait et que les autres
n'avaient pas c'était qu' son travail
était relié à l'histoire et à
l'actualité et il avait toujours ce truc
avec le mur de Berlin le les pays de
l'Est le le il mettait dans ses
histoires l'actualité distordue les mur
et le mur c'est c'est des séparations
c'est puis c'est un symbole très fort de
ce siècle c'est le mur de la de la
stupidité du du partage et ce mur de la
stupidit c'est le mur de Berlin mais le
mur de ce mur de stupidité de partage
tombe et il amène d'autres stupidités et
d'autres partages c'était très fascinant
je disa mais est-ce qu'un jour je
pourrais moi aussi raconter mes trucs en
Syrie comment je pourrais en faire de la
science-fiction mais c'était un embryon
de quelque chose mais quelque chose de
très très puissant il parlait vraiment
du monde j'en avais gardé aussi un
souvenir de la phrase finale une
dernière chose qui nicopole le héros
qu'est-ce qui va devenir on dit que l'
héros ne meurt jamais alors celui-là il
est certain qu'il ne Morra jamais parce
qu'il est immortel et ça c'est dur à
vivre ça c'est dur à vivre je trouvais
que c'était assez marrant il le disait
avec un une tête un peu insondable comme
ça sentait que ça ça le saoulait un
petit peu de faire cette ce reportage en
même temps qu'il était quand même
content il avait l'air était très beau
il avait 40 ans je crois 41 ans à
l'époque il avait la très sû de lui il
était extrêmement sérieux et donc c'est
marrant de se dire comme ça qu'une image
qu'on a entre perçu qu'on a vu un
soir dans la salle à manger avec ma avec
ma mère et tout ça puisse nous
poursuivre comme ça pendant pendant des
années